antoine bonjour cinq jours ont donc
passé depuis le déplacement de josep
borrell à moscou une visite qui continue
de faire des remous
oui tout à fait depuis son retour à
bruxelles le chef de la diplomatie
européenne s'est montré plus pressant
plus incisif envers la russie
dans un discours face au parlement
européen il s'est dit je cite préoccupé
par les perspectives des choix
géostratégiques des autorités russes et
de leurs implications pour l'europe et
pour le peuple russe de quoi l'inciter à
proposer de nouvelles sanctions contre
moscou pour le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères s'est
malheureusement sur à quoi on s'expose
quand on tente de mener une politique
étrangère non alignés écoutez vous voyez
quelle est l'évolution de la situation
sur la scène internationale toute
tentative de la russie de devenir
autonome et de faire valoir son droit à
une politique étrangère indépendante à
la protection du droit international se
heurte à une opposition de plus en plus
féroce de la part de ceux qui parmi nos
collègues occidentaux cherchent à nous
rendre en fin de compte docile à nous
faire accepter les interprétations assez
douteuse des valeurs humaines
universelles qu'il professe eux mêmes et
qui sont contraires à la tradition
culturelle russe à nos traditions
civilisationnel et veulent que la russie
soit en fin de compte un territoire
commode pour la promotion de leurs
propres intérêts dans le domaine de la
sécurité ainsi que sur le plan
économique politique et social
hop suisse nos politiques il y a aussi
eu vous l'avez évoqué les expulsions
prévisible de trois diplomates russes en
réponse au renvoi de trois diplomates
un suédois un polonais et un allemand le
5 février dernier accusé d'avoir
participé à un rassemblement en soutien
alexeï navalni enfin pour en revenir aux
menaces de sanctions contre la russie
celles ci seront discutées à l'occasion
de la réunion des ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'union européenne le 22
février puis lors d'un sommet le 3 mars
prochain
la visite de josep borrell n'aura donc
pas permis de réamorcer le dialogue
entre moscou et bruxelles
bien au contraire merci beaucoup antoine
cléroux depuis moscou